we've been a fond farewell to Cory
Booker Elizabeth Warren drops an anvil
on Bernie Sanders hen we examine
Bernie's political history i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show the
ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn your data is your business
protected at expressvpn calm slash pen
all righty tonight is the very last
democratic debate until the next
democratic debate but it is the last one
until Iowa and right now Joe Biden is
the man who is apparently in the lead in
Iowa according to a Monmouth University
poll released on Monday according to
Bloomberg the Biden is on top in Iowa as
more voters say they have firmly decided
on their choice Biden is currently ahead
with 24% support up five points from the
same poll in November Bernie Sanders is
in second place with 18% virtually tied
with Peabody judge at 17 and with
Elizabeth Warren at 15 Biden has been at
the top of most Iowa polls though
Sanders has had the lead in the Des
Moines Register CNN Mediacom poll
released on Friday with 20% by and was
fourth in that poll of 15 percent
support the Monmouth poll is notable
because 43 percent of respondents said
they are firmly decided on their top
choice that is up from 28 percent in
November as people are firming up their
choices they are finally settling on Joe
Biden I've said for a while here that
Joe Biden feels a lot like Mitt Romney
in 2012 in 2012 Mitt Romney was the
presumptive Republican nominee when he
jumped into the race yet of course come
in second to John McCain in 2008 and
then over the course of the race people
fell out of love with Mitt Romney over
and over and over everybody got a chance
at the top of that wheel of fortune
every single person Michele Bachmann
Herman Cain everybody got a chance in
2012 and then finally everybody come on
yeah okay I guess we'll give it to
Romney and it seems like that may be
happening with Joe Biden in recent weeks
Biden his thoughts revived a flagging
operation in Iowa spending more time in
the state and out laying more on online
and TV ads ahead of the February 3rd
caucus Biden's frontrunner status in
this poll could cause him to come under
fire from his rivals on Tuesday a six
Democratic candidates meet in Des Moines
for the final debate before the caucuses
along with Warren Sanders and Budaj
he faces Minnesota senator Amy Klobuchar
and billionaire activist Tom Styer steyr
is showing some signs of life in the
early States after a huge amount of
spending Amy Klobuchar has never been
able to really catch fire the poll also
revealed about more about who voters
would support as a second choice
according to Bloomberg
under Iowa caucus rules supporters of
candidates who don't receive at least
15% on the first round actually have to
switch to a viable candidate
so the second picks of supporters could
prove important so let's say that 8% of
people vote for Tom Styer well now they
have to switch she's gonna switch to
Warren leaves for second choice
23 percent said they would pick her if
their first choice did not make the cut
up from 17 percent in November Buda
judge was virtually tied with Sanders at
15 and 14 percent respectively Biden was
the second choice of only 10 percent in
other words it seems as though everybody
who is voting for Biden he is their
first choice they're not a lot of people
who are thinking okay well if Warren
falls out I'm moving over to Biden if
Warren drops out then probably that goes
to Sanders if Sanders drops out that
goes to Warren if bootie judge drops out
that probably breaks between all the
various candidates but when pollsters
asked likely caucus-goers who they would
pick if the only viable candidates in
their caucus site were in the top four
Biden said a 28 percent bootie judge of
25 Sanders of 24 Warren at 16% and one
person who will not be taking part in
the Iowa caucuses is of course Cory
Booker to whom we bid a fond farewell we
say goodbye to mr. Potato Head Cory
Booker there were good times there are
bad times mostly there were potato times
Cory Booker would go around pop in those
angry eyes blink deliberately
and then tell you how seriously he took
everything in the world well he released
a video explaining that he was very sad
to drop out this of course is prompted
the usual spasms of apoplexy from all of
the people in the media who are now
firmly convinced that Democrats are
racist again this part I like I will say
that I am enjoying the perpetual
revolution promised by the
intersectional advocates the way this
works is that if Democrats elect a black
president twice if they nominate a black
guy with no actual record over Hillary
Clinton in 2008 and then he becomes
president and then they do it again in
2012 that doesn't matter anymore
as long as you're not nominating a black
guy this time that means that you're
racist it's sort of how the Oscars work
also it doesn't matter that Lupita
Nyong'o actually won an Oscar for 12
years of slave in 2014 she wasn't
nominated this year that means that the
Academy is racist doesn't matter that
Greta Gerwig was nominated at the 2018
Oscars for Lady Bird she wasn't
nominated for Little Women
that means the Academy is sexist well
it's the same thing inside the
Democratic Party
Cory Booker ain't on the stage Kamala
Harris ain't on the stage that means of
course that the Democratic Party is
racist and I am here
or it's straight into my veins here's
Corey Booker announcing that his
candidacy is over I will say that the
music in this farewell video does not
really match the moment it really sounds
as though it's it's an ad for some sort
of tractor company but here is Cory
Booker I'm suspending my campaign for
president with the same spirit with
which it began it is my faith in us
faith in us together as a nation and we
share common pain and common problems
that can only be solved with a common
purpose and a sense of common cause so
now I recommit myself to the work I
can't wait to get back on the campaign
trail the campaign as hard as I can for
whoever is the eventual nominee and what
candidates up and down the ballot oh
that's so sad I mean what's rosario
Dawson gonna do now she had this whole
big campaign to her plan and now I guess
she's just gonna have to go back and be
like a French character on Daredevils
that's that's kind of sad well we'd
better find farewell again to mr.
Potatohead
and we hope that he always keeps with
him his angry eyes in a second we'll get
to the democratic debate itself first
let us talk about the reality which is
that as you grow older gentlemen the
chances are that you're gonna start
losing your hair I know because my
father lost his hair started losing his
hair in like his late 30s early 40s and
the truth is that a huge number of
Americans start losing their hair by the
time they are 35 the good news with
today's advancements in science keeps
offers proven treatments that can combat
the symptoms of hair loss in help you
keep the hair that you have at half the
cost of your local pharmacy and this is
one of those things where you really
have to work on prevention because there
ain't really a great answer once all
your hair is gone it ain't coming back
keeps will help you keep the hair that
you have which is why they call
themselves keeps keeps offers generic
versions are the only two FDA approved
hair loss products out there some of you
may have tried them before probably
never for this price plus keeps now
offers a prescription shampoo that keeps
your scalp healthy as well prevention is
key and keeps treatments really do work
they're up to 90% effective and reducing
and stopping further hair loss the
sooner you start using keeps the more
hair you will save so go act fast right
now many men do you experience some hair
growth with keeps treatment find out why
keeps has more 5-star reviews than any
of its competitors and nearly 100,000
men trust keeps for their hair loss
prevention medication keeps treatments
start at just ten bucks a month plus
four
to get that first month for free if
you're ready to take action go to keeps
calm slash been to receive your first
month of treatment for free that is ke
EPS calm slash been ke e PS calm slash
man keeps calm slash fun keep the hair
that you have and make sure that you
keep that hair going into the future ok
so as I say the media are very upset now
that Cory Booker is out they care about
him one who's running but now they're
very upset about it you Mischa Allison's
or commenting on MSNBC she suggested of
course then now it's an all-white
democratic to make these racist racist
Democrats who are oh so now what's
what's weird about that is the notion
that minority voters only vote for
minority candidates which of course is
untrue if you look at the democratic
caucuses one of the big problems for
Cory Booker and Kamala Harris is that
black voters have overwhelmingly
resonated to Joe Biden who's about as
white as white can be but the idea here
is that Democratic voters overall are
racist if they didn't somehow prop up a
candidate of color into the final sort
of four here is yummy elsens or PBS
newshour White House correspondent
talking about how this isn't all like
debate and expect to hear a lot of that
today
now that Cory Booker is out you really
have one african-american contender left
that's Deval Patrick and then you have
Andrew yang both of which have not
qualified for the next debate so next
debate at this point it's going to be an
overwhelmingly white debate a white
all-white debate and there are a lot of
Democratic voters that are wondering if
the Democrats are going to continue rely
on african-american voters and
specifically African American women for
their loyalty how they're going to
continue to make that case while not
having a feel that looks like the voters
they're trying to get they're gonna
bully one of these candidates into
picking Connell Harris's VP aren't they
I mean that that's the way this is going
to work they're gonna book they're gonna
bully Joe Biden into picking Kamala
Harris who he can't stand or Cory Booker
who has been running for VP for several
months here as a candidate just because
we can't have too many white people
that'd be very very bad too many white
people but as I say I I will enjoy it
while all of these candidates profess
their deep upset at the fact that
minority candidates have not been more
successful in the 2020 race it reminds
me of this this very famous novel by
Arthur Tesla called darkness at noon the
entire novel is about a Sophia Soviet
apparatchik had fought in the Russian
Revolution then had served under Stalin
who's eventually the revolution
eventually made the target of the
revolution during the 1938 purges and he
finds himself in jail and his choice is
whether to confess to treason which he
knows is not true or to stands up to the
regime and he chooses to confess to
treason because he has to go along with
the program even if the program eats him
and that that's exactly the Democratic
Party at this point you're gonna see all
of these Democrats who know that they
are not racist proclaiming that their
party is indeed racist because Kamala
Harris and Cory Booker aren't on that
stage meanwhile intersectionality fight
breaking out now between two very white
people Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth
Warren so they are going after each
other last night Elizabeth Warren tried
to drop a bomb on Bernie Sanders and
this is really egregious I mean and this
is I cannot stand that Elizabeth Warren
she is just the worst the reason that
she is just the worst is because she
pretends that she is as honest and true
as the day is long in truth is that she
has sold every one of the political
principles she held in about 2003 she's
thrown them out the window in order to
run as Bernie Sanders Lite and then she
pretended she was Bernie Sanders his
friend throughout this campaign and the
two of them laid off each other and
honestly I think Bernie Sanders as
you'll see in just a moment it's just an
egregious awful politician he has
terrible terrible views I think that he
has backed some of the worst regimes on
planet Earth I think he currently the
Hobnobs with some of the worst
anti-semites in Congress I mean he's
just he's just terrible but compared to
Elizabeth Warren at least man's honest
so last night Elizabeth Warren after
spending years proclaiming falsely to
choose a Native American and drops his
story she leaks this story that when she
and Bernie Sanders met in December 2018
Bernie Sanders told her he didn't think
that a woman could win the presidency
CNN reported this the stakes were high
when Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth Warren
met at Warren's apartment in Washington
DC one evening in December 2018 the
longtime friends knew that they could
soon be running against each other for
presidents the two agreed that if
ultimately they faced each other as
presidential candidates they should
remain civil and avoid attacking one
another so as not to hurt the
progressive movement they also discussed
how to best take on President Donald
Trump and Warren laid out two main
reasons she believed should be a strong
candidate she can make a robust argument
about the economy and she could earn
broad support from female voters Sanders
responded that he did not believe a
woman could win ah no you can't see you
can't see oh oh oh is it first of all
does Bernie Sanders really believe that
a woman could not win the presidency no
Bernie Sanders been saying for years
that he thinks that a woman could
certainly be President in 1988 he said a
woman could be president it is now 2009
2020 so it is now 30 it's now 32 years
later and Bernie Sanders did I mean he
had like a little more hair than but he
feels like the high school principal and
back to the future did that did that guy
ever have here anyway here's Bernie
Sanders in 1988 explaining that a woman
could be President the real issue is not
whether you're black or white whether
you're a woman or a man in my view a
woman could be elected president of the
United States the real issue is whose
side are you on are you on the side of
workers and poor people or are you on
the side of big money and the
corporation that as a man who has not
changed one iota accepts he speaks a
little bit slower today that's pretty
much it but Bernie Sanders who was
apparently an eight-year-old communist
when he was 40 the idea that he's going
around telling women that they can't win
the presidency because he doesn't like
women is silly now maybe Bernie Sanders
said I think against Donald Trump women
are gonna have a particular challenge
maybe he said that that happens to be a
fairly common political analysis in the
aftermath of Hillary Clinton losing the
2016 election to Donald Trump was about
as toxic a male as it is possible to
have in American politics according to
CNN that evening in 2018 Sanders
expressed frustration at what he saw as
a growing focus among Democrats on
identity politics according to one of
the people familiar with the
conversation Warren told Sanders she
disagreed with his assessment that a
woman could not win three of the four
sources said so Bernie Sanders was on
CNN and he denied the report he called
it a ludicrous report it is ludicrous to
believe that at the same meeting where
Elizabeth Warren told me she was going
to run for president I would tell her
that a woman couldn't win it's sad that
three weeks before the Iowa caucus and a
year after that private conversation
staff who weren't in the room are lying
about what happened what I did say that
night was that Donald Trump is a sexist
a racist and a liar who would weaponize
whatever he could do I believe a woman
can win in 2020 of course after all
Hillary Clinton beat Donald Trump by
three million votes in 2016 okay now as
we will see
Elizabeth Warren is doing me I didn't
leak this but he did say that he did
then who leaked it really you think that
nobody from a Warren campaign leaked it
there's Bernie surrogates and Warren
surrogates in that meeting did you
really think then nobody from Elizabeth
Warren seemed like this like the day
before the debate so that it's a debate
topic do you really think that Elizabeth
Warren isn't playing cynical politics in
the last moments the campaign she is so
gross she really is just an awful he
just really terrible in just a second
we'll get to Elizabeth Warren confirming
that Bernie did indeed say that a woman
could not win oh oh no he must be a
brutal sexist these people are so
tiresome now I do feel sort of like that
guy from Godzilla let them fight I'm
going to enjoy it at the same time you
got to feel a little bit bad for Bernie
he's just over there being a useless
socialist and getting some getting some
momentum and here comes Elizabeth Warren
stomping through that front door in
traditional Native American garb
suggesting that he is is sexist it's got
to be a little bit rough to be a
Democrat honestly I'll get two more on
this in just one second first let's talk
about the fact that when you are
building a business one of your chief
cost is probably gonna be legal it can
cost an absolute dang fortune to spend
money on your legal expenses when you're
starting a business or when you are
running a business and this is why you
should be using LegalZoom I've been
using Legal Zoom for years like long
before they were an advertiser on this
program I was using Legal Zoom in order
to do wills and trusts in order to do
simple contracts LegalZoom has become
incredibly sophisticated make 2020 the
year you officially start your business
or sort out that will over living trusts
or whatever it is you're waiting for
over the past 19 years Legal Zoom has
helped more than four million people I
am one of those people they provide the
resources you need to confidently
resolve your personal and business legal
needs you can get started quickly online
and if you have questions or need advice
they have the right people to help you
out too Legal Zoom is not a law firm so
you can count on their network of
independent attorneys for advice at the
right price since they do not charge by
the hour that's the way you rack up
those big legal charges you get a
partner charging you 600 bucks an hour
not at Legal Zoom go to legalzoom.com
today enter the promo code been in the
box at checkout for special savings
that's legalzoom.com promo code Ben
legalism is where life meets legal they
will save you a fortune and they will
save you an enormous amount of time go
check them out
legalzoom.com promo code Ben okay so
elizabeth warren has come out and
confirm
the report shocker shocker because she
leaked it she says Bernie and I met for
more than two hours in December 2018 to
discuss the 2020 election our past work
together and our shared goals beating
Donald Trump taking back our government
from the wealthy and well-connected and
building an economy that works for
everyone
among the topics that came up was what
would happen if Democrats nominated a
female candidate I thought a woman could
win he disagreed I have no interest in
discussing this private meeting any
further because Bernie and I have far
more in common than our differences on
punditry I'm in this race to talk about
what's broken in this country and how to
fix it and that's what I'm going to
continue to do i know bernie is in the
race for the same reason we have been
friends and allies in this fight for a
long time i have no doubt we will
continue to work together to defeat
Donald Trump and put our government on
the side of the people okay so she
absolutely leaked us she absolutely did
so in scurrilous fashion she absolutely
is seeking to sink Bernie Sanders among
women said she hopes that she can pick
up a few more votes in Iowa and New
Hampshire and maybe be a legit contender
for the presidency it's a brutal and
terrible hit it's a really dishonest hit
by Elizabeth Warren and there was
absolutely no question this came from
Elizabeth Warren's camp and I do love
her take this story that my team leaked
and that I'm currently putting out a
statement on I expect no further
questions and watches the media humor
her seriously watches the media pretend
that she doesn't need to be asked about
any of those questions I mean at least
Chris Cuomo block of wood Chris Cuomo
the dummer of the Cuomo brothers at
least Chris Cuomo is honest about this
one he says you know if you're going to
bring up this topic then you might be
asked questions about it I have no
interest in discussing this private
meeting any further because Bernie and I
have far more in common than our
differences note to self if you don't
want to talk about it then you should
have never put out the statement if
Bernie Sanders doesn't want to talk
about it he should have never denied it
now you've got competing allegations
somebody's not telling the truth
yeah well it's it's pretty obvious what
happened here which is probably that
Bernie made an offhand comment about how
he thought that a woman might be at a
disadvantage against Trump because Trump
is so vicious all right that's the kind
of thing Bernie would say does that mean
that Bernie is natural sexist who
doesn't believe that a woman can be
president of course not he just got beat
by a woman in the primaries in the last
go-around so the whole thing is
unbelievably silly so on that level I
have a bit of sympathy for Bernie and
then
is the political level we're burning is
just a garbage fire so the fact that
Bernie Sanders is taken seriously by the
Democratic Party the fact that this guy
is one of the top two candidates the
fact that he really did have a
significant amount of momentum going
into this week's politics it just shows
you how far the Democratic Party has
skewed to the left I mean this guy was
an independent four years in the Senate
specifically because he was too far left
for the Democratic Party he was an
independent in Vermont you know how
left-wing you have to be to be an
independent in Vermont your my goodness
that's it is it's bizarre okay Bernie
Sanders his record is egregiously
egregiously far-left and that is why
even people like chris matthews who's
sort of a a normal left winger even
chris matthews he gets up in the morning
put down a rep up soap come on here have
an iron my shirt coming out of a show
that's my tears there used to be and
that coming right I see John Kerry's
face looks like it's collapsing a
mudslide from 1994 El Nino instead of
California huh and then I tell him
Bernie's the worst and then we laugh
about it together I say haha and Jack
Harry says uh-huh go kiss Matthews go
you get the wrong candidate you might
lose the whole thing what about Bernie
Sanders do you think he's a danger as
the president as a candidate you're out
there fighting like hell for Joe Biden
how much of danger is that Bernie
Sanders is now leading in the polls in
the latest poll out there in Iowa how
big a danger would he be to the country
or to the party the Democrats
let me get a stop out right up the
middle John Kerry tell me how much my
danger over Bernie Sanders may have here
than a man--a and we may be as dangerous
as me
ice skating around a rink behind an
elephant just random stuff but here's
the thing but first math isn't wrong and
Bernie Sanders is in fact a candidate
who's not likely to win the hearts and
minds of the American people and people
who think that it is are a little bit
delusional about exactly who Bernie
Sanders is they've obscured his past his
40-year long history of being an actual
communist in order to shield from the
fact that he is natural communist right
if you wanna make him electable you
can't talk about anything he's done for
40 years instead you have to buy his
nonsense now that he only likes Finland
he only likes Norway he only likes
Denmark he never I never liked Venezuela
I was never
of Cuba or Nicaragua or the Soviet Union
except for all the years when I was
actually putting a penance for Stalin in
my home I bought the pendant of Stalin
it went right next to my Brooklyn
Dodgers pennant and I put it up in my
home and each night I would sing the
Soviet Union national anthem but let me
tell you I was never a fan I was never a
fan they didn't have enough pudding so
here's the problem for Bernie Sanders
dude was actually like a full-on
Tommy and continues to be right he just
sort of shields it now
so let's look back at Bernie's record
briefly according to Andrew Kaczynski
Nathan McDermott is from March 14th 2019
over at CNN Bernie Sanders advocated for
the nationalization of most major
industries including energy companies
factories and banks when he was a
leading member of a self-described
radical political party in the 1970s by
the way in the 1970s Bernie Sanders was
still 72 years old Bernie Sanders his
past views shed light on a formative
period of his political career that
could become relevant as he advances in
the 2020 Democratic primary many of the
positions he held at the time are more
extreme compared to the more tempered
democratic socialism the Vermont senator
espouses today and could provide fodder
for moderate Democrats and Republicans
looking to cast the Democratic
presidential candidate and his beliefs
as a fringe form of socialism that would
be harmful to the country aspects of
Sanders his plans and time in the
Liberty Union have been reported before
but the material taken together
including hundreds of newly digitalized
newspapers and files from the Liberty
Union party archives at the University
of Vermont paint a fuller picture in a
statement to CNN Sanders campaign
spokesperson Josh Orton said last year
throughout his career Bernie has fought
on the side of working people and
against the influence of both the
powerful ultra rich and giant
corporations who seek only to further
their own greed the record shows that
from the very beginning bernie
anticipated and worked to combat the
rise of a billionaire ruling class and
the exploding power of Wall Street and
multinational corporations
Bernie's priority has always been and
always will be defending the interests
of working people across the country
that does not sound right there so much
like an apology does it I'm not getting
the apology there from Bernie Sanders
okay so a little bit more on Bernie
Sanders in the Liberty Union party after
moving to Vermont in 1968 according to
CNN several years after graduating
college Sanders became an active member
of the left-wing Liberty Union party
under the Liberty Union banner Sanders
then in his early
thirty's by Bernie Sanders back in the
1970s at the same age that I was now he
ran for governor of Vermont in 1972 and
1976 and then as a candidate for Senate
in 72 and 74 didn't do great Sanders
also served as chairman of the party
from 73 to 75 during this time Sanders
and Liberty Union argued for
nationalization of the energy industry
which worked out amazingly well for the
oil industry in Venezuela bankrupting
the country and leading to people eating
dogs in the streets public ownership of
banks which typically has gone
hand-in-hand with a complete
socialization of lending which has ended
with a death of entrepreneurship
telephone electric and drug companies
and of the major means of production
such as factories in capital as well as
other proposals such as a 100 percent
income tax on the highest income earners
in America so he's a fallen communist I
mean this is just communism right every
element of this is social ownership of
the means of production which is to say
state ownership of the means of
production that is the definition of
communism Bernie Sanders was full on for
it and when asked about it he was like I
always looked up for working people
working people the proletariat you might
say they should break that chance they
might say that the workers of the world
should you like and if there are a few
gulags there are a few gulags Sanders
also rejected political violence and
criticized the anti-democratic nature of
communist states such as the Soviet
Union that was always the communist way
in the United States of winking and
nodding at the Soviet Union with it I do
not like the violence in the Soviet
Union put boy dude they have wonderful
health care this has been Bernie
Sanders's position for a long time in
one in one interview in 1976 Sanders
said I favor the public ownership of
utilities banks and major industries so
that's some pretty wild stuff and it
turns out that Bernie Sanders has been
fairly consistent about all of this Paul
Sperry had a column in January of 2016
talking about how Sanders was in actual
communist he says while attending the
University of Chicago Sanders joined the
young people's socialist league a youth
wing of the Socialist Party USA he also
organized for a communist front the
United packinghouse Workers Union which
at the time was under investigation by
the House Committee on American
activities then he moved to Vermont
where he headed the American people's
History Society in Oregon for Marxist
propaganda where he produced the glowing
documentary on the life of socialist
revolutionary Eugene Debs
apparently he still hangs a portrait of
eugene debs on his wall in his Senate
office which is pretty astonishing that
was as of 2016 in 1918 Deb's announced
his solidarity with Lenin and Trotsky
and then of course as we just mentioned
Sanders helped found the Liberty Union
party which called for the
nationalization of everything and then
after he failed in 1981 he managed to
get elected mayor of Burlington Vermont
where he restricted property rights for
landlords set price controls raised
property taxes to pay for communal land
Trust's local small businesses hands it
out flyers complaining the mayor's had
quote not believe in free enterprise and
then he took a bunch of goodwill trips
to various communist dictatorships
around the world or he was very angry at
the violence but also they seem like
pretty great places did they not in 1985
he traveled to Managua to celebrate the
rise to power of the Marxist Leninist
sandanista government which was
slaughtering its opponents he called it
a heroic revolution and he undermined
anti-communist US policy denouncing the
Reagan administration backing the
Contras in a letter to the Sandinistas
he even tried to broker a peace deal and
invited Sansa needs to leader Daniel
Ortega to visit the United States he
exalted Ortega as an impressive guy
while attacking President Reagan I mean
yes the this is who Bernie Sanders was
and I've seen not a lot of evidence that
Bernie said I mean he's never repudiated
any of this and no point did he turn
around and say yeah by the way this is a
this is this was a mistake
I went too far it was beautiful
exuberance 47 but there was youthful
exuberance I mean I'm not 1,000 years
old I was just a baby I'm basically like
baby yoga I'm eight years old but I was
still a baby today Sanders wants to
bring what he admired in the USSR cuba
nicaragua and other communist states to
the United States according to Paul
Sperry and obviously his program for a
government spending is extraordinarily
ambitious to put it kindly but don't
don't just ask me about it ask Bernie
about it back in 1986 Bernie suggested
that JFK's response to the rise of the
Castro's made him want to puke that
would be the Castros who were busy
shooting dissidents in the streets
jailing them and then imposing communal
land ownership and wrecking the economy
of Cuba such that people in 2020 are
still driving around Chevy's from the
1950s when they're not at something to
float them to the coast of Florida
Kennedy was saying that Nixon was too
soft on communism may pick up a point
that Rick was making in Cuba we
should deal firmly with Fidel Castro and
Nixon was playing the role of hey you
got to be patient you know you can't do
these things you got to negotiate would
of course what he was upset about is
that secretly they were planning the Bay
of Pigs invasion right then but for
security reasons he come it couldn't
come out and say we already planning the
destruction of the Cuban Revolution
don't worry about it so he he was too
liberal and Kennedy was playing the
conservator actually you know there when
you read novels people say there's a
sick feeling in your stomach usually I'm
sufficiently unemotional not to be sick
but actually got up in the room and
almost left the pubic yeah must let the
puke when I found out that the United
States opposed the communist revolution
that ended with the slaughter of people
who actually wanted to just keep that
property back in the day Bernie was also
praising breadlines Bernie loves bread
lines actually right this is the same
period where he was explaining that
bread bread lines felt good because
their lines for bread why should you let
that fly into bread it's like a grocery
store bread lines are good you know
those whose good masturbation also
gulags Bernie Sanders looks funny
sometimes American journalists talk
about how country's people in other
countries rich people get food and poor
people starve to death like the United
States but when they have bread lines
everything is great because nobody gets
bread but there is a line and I like
lines have you ever danced in the conga
line have you ever done the Macarena let
me ask you back have you ever done a
proper conga line or a proper Macarena
you don't see that in the United States
well cultural heritage is restricted to
the Charleston and square dancing have
you ever seen such a thing
okay back by the way back back then
Bernie Sanders is also praising Soviet
infrastructure I just love how this
entire period of his career has been
wiped clean as though he doesn't believe
all these things and when he's asked
about it he doesn't apologize as you'll
see in just a moment when Bernie Sanders
is asked to openly about this stuff he
doesn't back off of it it's not as
though Bernie has decided that he
changed his mind like over the course I
listen I've been doing this since I was
17 since the timeout so almost 20 years
in that time some of my views have
changed some of them moderated some of
them become stronger and this happens
over time and when I have changed my
view on something I tried to be open
about the views that have changed and if
somebody asks me about it I will say
that my views have changed you can find
tons of tape of me online talking about
this
Bernie Sanders has not changed his views
so
she was campaigning with Trotsky here is
Bernie Sanders talking about Soviet
infrastructure and the wonders of Soviet
infrastructure by the way this is like a
couple years before the Soviet Union
collapsed because it turns out it was a
garbage heap most of the people here
also were extremely impressed by their
public transportation system the
station's themselves were absolutely
beautiful including many works of art
chandeliers that were beautiful it was a
very very effective system also I was
impressed by the youth programs that
they have their palaces of of culture
for the young people a whole variety of
young programs for young people and
cultural programs which go far beyond
what we do in this country
unbelievable cultural programs they
teach you to sing about how great Stalin
was and then also they teach you to
dance about how great Stalin was and
then when you're finished singing and
dancing they teach you to recite poetry
about how great Stalin was its cultural
genius over there as opposed to the
United States the inventor of jazz rock
and roll musical theater movies they've
got actual culture over there actual
unbelievable great culture and only one
flavor of pudding because you only need
one flavor pudding and it isn't the
tapioca Bernie Sanders again this
guy might win the Democratic nomination
how nuts is 1/4 of the country right now
like full-on crazy completely crazy I'll
get to that in just one second first if
you're not already a daily where a
member you are truly missing out right
now using promo code Shapiro you'll get
10% off any plan that you choose head
over to Taylor wire.com slash subscribe
and pick the plan that is right for you
that's right 10% off for as little as 10
bucks a month members get our articles
ad free access to all of our live
broadcast and shall library the full
three hours of the Ben Shapiro show
select bonus content access to the
mailbag and more plus our new all-access
tier gets you into exclusive live online
Q&A discussions with me
Andrew Clavin Matt Walsh Michael Moe's
plus daily wire writers and special
guests and don't forget you also get the
very greatest of all beverage vessels
the left is tears hot or cold tumblr yes
you get all of those wondrous glories
plus 10% off that's right 10% off like
go do it right now you never won know
when the deals were going to come or
when they're going to go will they blow
higher while they blow low
go check them out right now get all of
those wonders plus 10% off use promo
code Shapiro which you should remember
because you're listening to my show
so stop depriving yourself come join the
fun plus the way you want to insulate us
against a left that is going to try and
come after us this year like nobody's
business join the team like people often
will ask me how do I help how do I help
the the conservative movement there are
lots of ways to help one of the ways you
can help it sounds all suffering but
it's true is to help insulate the
outlets that you love from the blowback
that they receive from the left which
seeks to target their advertisers and
seeks to ruin them when you join the
team you make sure that we can continue
bringing you the content that you need
go check us out right now daily where I
come and use promo code appear to get
10% off we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
okay so when I say the Bernie Sanders
has not changed like ever this week he
did an interview with the with the New
York Times it's a very very long
interview and he was asked specifically
about his opinions on Latin America so
Latin America is a favorite it's a
favourite topic for folks on the left
and no I'm Chomsky left people like him
to suggest that the United States has
been interventionist in South America in
unbelievably terrible ways because the
United States worked sometimes
right-wing dictators in order to fight
communists insurgencies in south america
which is true because the united states
has acted through the monroe doctrine to
prevent great powers from intervening in
latin america because it happens to be a
fact of life and of history that when
the United States was quote-unquote
imperialist in particular areas of the
world that has generally been in order
to counter imperialism from countries
across the sea that goes all the way
back to the eighteen really the 1820s
and the Monroe Doctrine the notion that
no European country should set foot in
the Western Hemisphere but Bernie
Sanders has asked a simple question by
one of the members of the New York Times
editorial board quote you've long
supported movements in Latin America to
oppose American intervention and
oppressive regimes there why do you
think it is that so many of the leftist
governments that have taken power in the
last few years
despite the hopes that many American
left his had that they would bring about
change have become anti-democratic
corrupts and even brutal and that is
just a simple fact okay and Bernie
Sanders his response to this is what
about all the right-wing people in Latin
America is well for us not compared to
what what I have opposed my whole life
is us interventionism
and overthrowing governments well except
for the fact that you did stand in favor
of Daniel Ortega is alright as you are
familiar with the United States has a
long history under the so-called Monroe
Doctrine of overthrowing governments I
don't think that is right only
communists should be able to overthrow
governments because workers of the world
should rise up and break the fetters
alright I think it was wrong to
overthrow Salvador Allende in Chile it
was wrong to overthrow the Brazilian
government wrong to overthrow the
government in the mannequin republic
wrong to overthrow the Grenadian
government you know it's just big
brother thinking they have a right to
intervene whatever they wanted in Latin
America now you raise an interesting
question first of all when we talk about
recent governments Lula this would be
the former president of Brazil if I
talked to a couple of weeks ago we can
argue it now I'm not telling you I'm the
world's greatest expert but I suspect
the case against them was an
illegitimate case
is corrupt to his bones and was charged
and was found guilty of corruption and
then he talks about yeah you're balsa
narrow he says he IRA Belson arrow is a
dictator and then he praises Evo Morales
of Bolivia whose record is not
particularly good which is why there was
a coup in Bolivia that was democratic
who's attempting to oust Morales after
he attempted to change the constitution
single-handedly the the New York Times
editorial board even came out and said
the Morales had quote shed his
legitimacy as a leader because of his
attempts to destroy the constitutional
republic and then he talks about Mexico
he says in Mexico well you have drug
cartels massive amount of corruption in
terms about the countries so I'm not
sure I accept the basic premises Lulla I
think did a good job in Brazil the
people of Brazil did not think so I
didn't more ellas probably should not
have run again but his record is not a
bad record and somebody asked him about
Nicaraguan they said Ortega is a good
exception to the rule who came back to
power way in the 1980s and has since
become a dictator I think that's
unfortunate but don't only look to
leftist governments and any tax policy
narrow bohlson arrows is not a dictator
Oh sinner Oh entered office like two
years ago the hell are you talking about
you're comparing that to Daniel Ortega
your take has been in power for like
decades what are you saying
and then he's asked about Venezuela he
says I assume that Venezuela would be
one of the exceptions on that list as
well there's AG up yup and then by the
way Sanders has warned against
intervention in Venezuela so basically
there's not a left-wing dictatorship on
planet earth he is willing to attack but
he's willing to declare non dictators
who happened to be right-wing dictators
in order to push his nonsense so Bernie
Sanders has always been deeply radical
that has not ended that has not stopped
and when you listen to him talk about
what exactly he wants to do in his first
100 days it's it's wild so he's asked
what would his first 100 days look like
and here is what he says he says it's
going to be a busy hundred days in fact
I've made enough promises I think I'm
going to be up all night on my first day
I'm gonna go to bed at 5:00 in the
morning I think the most important point
aside from the legislation is to
convince the American people that in
fact we can have a government that
represents working people and not just
the 1% and then the notion that the
American government has ever represented
only the 1% is absolute nonsense it's
been absolute nonsense for all of
American history and it is particularly
learned
since today he says obviously the
legislation what going to introduce will
deal with climate change which I
considered to be an enormous threat not
only to this country but to the planet
will introduce medicare-for-all
legislation in the first week yeah
that's only gonna cost us a minimum of
32 trillion dollars over 10 years it
will likely cost much more than that
there has yet to be a government
estimate of cost that even remotely
approaches what the actual cost looks
like when he was set up the government
program he says will be introducing
legislation not dissimilar to what the
House passed raising the minimum wage to
a living wage he would like to see the
House of Representatives raise the
federal minimum wage to $15 an hour
which of course will not cause any
unemployment in the teenage ranks that's
exactly what happens when a minimum wage
is raised the people who retain their
jobs have a higher minimum wage
everybody else is unemployed and this
particularly creates a downward pressure
on labor because it means that if you
were less qualified you can no longer
get the 725 an hour job because now it's
paying 15 bucks an hour that one's gonna
go to you know a college junior or
something he also says that he's going
to introduce legislation to rebuild our
infrastructure make public colleges and
universities tuition-free he's gonna do
all this in the first hundred days and
he's gonna do it magically cuz he was
asked it how are you who's asked are you
gonna do this because Mitch McConnell is
in the Senate and he says that the
agenda is supported by the American
people so I'm gonna yell about it that's
his plan he's going to actually just
stand there and yell he says it's
rallying the American people around in
the agenda that they already support all
right okay that guy is your possible
frontrunner and that is why so many
Democrats are looking around and going
you know maybe this Biden guy isn't the
scariest guy maybe we should go with the
Biden guy because at least he ain't in
old Tommy we seen an old commie a
meanwhile the the hubbub over
impeachment continues apparently
according to the hill GOP leadership
believes there are not 51 votes to
dismiss the Trump articles and
impeachment right away which is not a
shock it is not surprising that the the
Republicans do not have a pre-emptive
dismissal prepared senator roy blunt of
missouri told reporters on Monday the
Senate Republican caucus does not have
the votes to dismiss the articles of
impeachment against President Trump who
endorsed an outright dismissal over the
weekend blunt said I think our members
generally are not interested in a motion
to dismiss certainly there aren't 51
votes for a motion to dismiss president
Trump has been trying
to push all of that but the fact is that
the Republicans are not gonna go for
that they're gonna run through the
process and then they are not going to
vote to impeach him and then that is
going to be that there's also a poll out
today from Quinnipiac suggesting that a
majority of Americans are interested in
hearing from John Bolton which is again
not a surprise the media have been
stumping on this very hard they suggest
that John Bolton of course is moments
away from giving the testimony that's
going to break president Trump Chuck
Schumer the Senate Minority Leader is
saying the Bolton should be subpoenaed
which is weird because he wasn't saying
the same thing when Nancy Pelosi in
charge of the house didn't subpoena John
Bolton no trial will be a fair trial
without witnesses and documents and john
bolton is a key witness and so he should
be subpoenaed and if he is subpoenaed
executive privilege won't stop him they
tried to invoke executive privilege
against fiona hill they tried to invoke
executive privilege against william
taylor they tried to invoke executive
privilege against Sunderland
but since they wanted to go ahead and
testify they did and Bolton could do
just the same if you're wondering why I
only spent a couple minutes every show
talking about impeachment it's because
it's completely waste of time this is
not going anywhere Bolton's not gonna
get up there and give a bombshell
testimony that breaks president Trump's
presidency that's not where any of this
is gonna go Democrats however would
certainly rather focus on that than they
would on president Trump's victory over
the last couple of weeks in Iran the
American public increasingly are
basically in favor of what Trump did
with regard to Soleimani Trump's never
going to show up in the polls this way
what I mean is that if you ask the
American people if they ever approve of
anything from to us only about 45% will
ever say yes ever because the other 55%
have been taught by the media that it's
very very bad to say anything nice about
President Trump ever I mean the media
essentially suggests that if you're seen
within a 30 foot radius of President
Trump you'd become absolutely toxic last
night people went nuts because the actor
Vince Vaughn was in a luxury box with
the President of the United States at
the college football national
championship game
people running nuts over this okay first
of all Vince Vaughn has been a
Republican for a very long time
he's been very open about this Vaughn is
a libertarian he's been a very outspoken
liberal hearing people going nuts at
houck oh my god he's shaking Donald
Trump's hand I guess that you you can't
watch swingers anymore cuz Vince Vaughn
shook president Trump's hand that's in
that's totally crazy how could no no is
the American
like know that there's blowback for even
suggesting any warmth at all toward
president Trump's policies so what you
end up with is for any action about 45%
will say that it's good the question is
how many say that it's bad because if
that percent is low that means that like
30 percent of Americans are happy with
it but they're not going to say so
perfect example according to Quinnipiac
slightly more American voters say that
the killing of the top irani in general
was the right action for the United
States to take with 45 percent saying it
was the right action 41 percent saying
it was the wrong action however 45
percent say the killing of Qasem
Soleimani has made Americans less safe
while 32 percent say it has made
Americans more safe 18 percent say it
has had no impact on the safety of
Americans okay those are actually good
numbers for Trump because that means
that 50 percent say that the killing of
Soleimani didn't actually make American
America less safe
and it says that a plurality of
Americans say that killing soleimani was
the right action also a vast majority of
voters 58 percent believe that the
tensions between the United States and
Iran will not lead to war only 29
percent believe that it will lead to war
and that is led by a even the Democratic
Party is evenly split on that question
so you know President Trump gets a win
with regard to Iran the Democrats
continue to pretend that the Trump
administration did something deeply
wrong and killing its Soleimani there's
amazing to watch the same Democrats who
suggested that the Obama administration
did not lie in the aftermath of Benghazi
that the thing was not a terror attack
was the spontaneous uprising caused by a
random YouTube video the same media who
say that was not a scandal suggested is
a scandal that Trump suggested that
Soleimani was going to participate in
imminent terror when that was literally
his job and I praised Chris Cuomo
earlier I'm gonna correct that error now
here's Chris Cuomo of CNN suggesting the
president Trump's plan on Iran is to lie
deny and defy how about this how about
the media's plan on Iran is to back the
Obama narrative even even weeks after it
had been openly debunked the Trump
triple step is in full effect once again
what is it lie
deny defy take Iran it was imminent
because Iran is bad and this guy was a
terrorist okay but why imminent crickets
no proof that it was period the
the president denies that fact and says
it was about the embassy that they hit
in the past and for more something even
his inner circle
can't back up well I denied if I
alternatively you could just notice that
some LaVon II was a lifelong terrorist
yes Trump has a habit of getting over
his skis and saying things that are not
true or embellishing does that undermine
the central point was its own money was
a terrorist and needed to die no it does
not undermine that pointed out but the
media are gonna focus on the trees
specifically so they can avoid focusing
on the forest okay time for a quick
thing I like and then a quick thing that
I hate so things that I like today so
I've just recently completed a read of
Ludwig von Mises socialism and economic
and sociological analysis it is amazing
how bad ideas never die they they never
even really fade when my sees really
debunked socialism marks of socialism
from beginning to end and many other
types of socialism ranging from the
syndicalism to to gilded socialism he
does all of that in this this what at
the time was very famous book socialism
an economic and sociological analysis he
did that in nineteen twenty
okay so socialism has always been a
rotten idea it was never practical the
Austrian School of Economics ranging
from Schumpeter to Hayek to von Mises
did an excellent job of debunking the
theoretical underpinnings of socialism
and in the process debunking a lot of
the idiocy of Keynesianism and
government intervention ISM as well but
we prefer to ignore all of that because
the lure of socialism the lure of what
if we just had the wisest among us
delegating power to the rest of us and
determining what was fair and correcting
all cosmic and balances the the ring of
power is incredibly seductive it's
incredibly seductive the fatal conceit
that we are so wise that we can control
the economy top-down is incredibly
seductive and by the way you see it on
the right and the left these days you
see it on the right to people suggesting
that if we just correct the economy if
we just chained up the economy and make
it work for us why do we work for the
free markets why don't the free markets
work for us that's that's idiotic that's
like saying why don't we make breathing
work for us as opposed to working for
breathing free markets are just a
recognition that individuals have rights
they have a right to own their own labor
they've right to dispense with their own
labor as they see fit they have a right
to alienate their own labor
right to do anything they want with
their own labor and mutual exchange is a
matter of consent right recognising
those basic principles brings you to the
free market suggesting that the
collective need overrides those
individual principles eventually leads
you down the road to tyranny now that
doesn't mean that you always end up in
tyranny sometimes you're sort of half
charity sometimes you end up with
violations of property rights that are
minimal sometimes you end up with
at the ultimate extreme as you see in
the Soviet Union but the bottom line is
that socialism as a theory was never
workable von Mises debunked it
thoroughly in 1920 we are now a hundred
years later and people are pretending
that has not been debunked that somehow
there is there's some new information
out there that is going to somehow solve
the knowledge problem the idea that the
entire economy has more information than
any cadre of wise folks at the top and
there are people who are suggesting that
somehow computers are gonna solve all
this algorithms are gonna solve the the
vagaries of the market yeah except for
the fact that people don't actually know
what they want until an entrepreneur
actually creates a new product and
creates a dynamic economy one of the
great conceits of both right and left
when it comes to government running the
economy or government intervention ISM
the economy is the notion that
government has the capacity not only to
pick winners and losers but also to
forecast what comes next and this is
obviously foolish it's obviously not
true the great developments in human
history have been responses to market
needs that people did not even know
existed if you had asked people this is
a famous sort of Henry Ford apocryphal
statement if you had asked people in
1890 what they were looking for in a
form of transportation they would've
said a faster horse people don't know
what they want until somebody invents
something new until somebody creates a
new product until that product meets the
price point at which people are willing
to pay and when you hear socialists
suggest that profit margin is innate
evil this is like the aoc view and the
Bernie Sanders view that profit is greed
profit is greater is the profit margin
that provides the incentive structure
that leads to the development of new
better processes that leads products to
become cheaper and more plentiful and
more available and it is the price
mechanism of the market itself a price
mechanism that cannot be set by
government because not only do they not
have the information even if they did
have information they'd have to get it
from some sort of outside market as a
point
my C's makes the the notion that a an
entirely socialist earth wherein no
price mechanism exists that you could
then define the price of labor in that
that you can't define labor that way
because how would you know which labor
is more valuable which labor is not the
only way you can do that is by
submitting the product of the labor to
the market and determining how much of
somebody's labor they wish to trade in
favor of somebody else's product that
that's the only way to determine what
things are worth and we're so operating
under the labor theory of value which is
that things are worth the amount of work
that people put into them that is
obviously untrue
people on the right and the left buy
enter this nonsense it is economically
untrue it is logically untrue it's
clearly untrue if you ask somebody what
is more what what is more valuable an
hour of labor and a coal mine or an hour
of a man tinkering on a machine in his
garage in 1982 most people say an hour
of work in the coal mine but if it turns
out that the guy tinkering in his garage
on a computer in 1982 is Bill Gates well
then you might be wrong turns out the
market provides good an excellent
barometer of subjective value see the
thing is that every decision that you
make is a subjective decision insofar as
the value of a particular good service
or product from the fact that the left
refuses to acknowledge this and
increasingly people on the right refuse
to acknowledge it they think that there
is some sort of objective value that can
be assessed in a good or a product or a
service and that the government can
therefore set it and get rid of the
profit margin and then because the
profit margin is gone develop products
more efficiently this ignores the fact
that the market is as Schumpeter put it
in a part a machine of creative
destruction and that all the good stuff
you have in your life the reason you
live better now than your parents did in
1950 is because of all of the
entrepreneurs who are creating new
products and services and all the
competition that made those luxury
products available to the masses the
economy is not in fact stagnant I said
this many times socialism the only thing
it's good for is redistributing products
that exist in the here-and-now that's
the only thing that the government can
do the government can not produce more
efficiently than the free market nor can
the government develop new products and
services that have the capacity to reach
the entire American market at least not
without going about it at the expense of
the actual market itself the only way
you can tell what people want is to ask
them and
fact that people refuse to recognize
this is because people refuse to read
books go check out ludwig von mises
socialism not an easy read but an
important read already a quick thing
that I hate so I will acknowledge that I
think there are a lot of good movies
that were made this year the Academy
Awards nominations cannot yesterday I
think there are a lot of good movies
I've already praised Ford versus Ferrari
I've already praised 1917 I've already
praised Once Upon a Time and how a lot
of good movies this year but apparently
the Oscars are again very white and very
sexist and this led Issa Rae is the star
of some show whose name I cannot recall
on HBO she was announcing the director
nominees and this of course means that
she gets to sound off about how sexist
the Academy is the irishman martin
scorsese seventeen Sam Mendes Once Upon
a Time in Hollywood
Quentin Tarantino congratulations to
those men there's a sort of soft laugh
shoot the hose she's the the star of the
the show is called insecure she got all
sorts of plaudits for this look at her
strength and power and standing up to
the men in her industry hey the one who
everybody was whining about was Greta
Gerwig who directed Little Women she
also directed Lady Bird and was
nominated for Best Director two years
ago so apparently between then and now
the Oscars have gotten very racist and
very sexist again which is exciting news
it is
I will admit a little bit fun to watch
Hollywood eat its own alright we'll be
back here later today with two
additional hours of content so make sure
that you stick around for that otherwise
show up here tomorrow i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Rebecca Dodd poets directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producers Mathis Glover and Robert
Stirling technical producer Austin
Stephens associate producer Colton Haas
assistant director Pablo why douse key
edited by Adam Sai events audio is mixed
by Mike Romina hair and makeup is by
Jessica alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20 on the Matt Walsh oh we're not just
discussing politics we're talking
culture faith family all of the things
that are really important to you so come
join the conversation
[Music]